y el fiscal general de Venezuela anunció
este lunes que la fuerza pública ha
detenido a 55 personas y ha ejecutado
142 allanamientos en todo el país se
trata de operaciones enmarcadas en la
Macro lucha contra la corrupción que
proclamó recientemente el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro Las investigaciones sobre
delitos económicos implican a
trabajadores y altos cargos relacionados
con la siderúrgica corporación
venezolana de guayana y con la empresa
Estatal petróleos de Venezuela pedevesa
personas y negocios que orbitaban en
torno a la figura de tareke lysami un
hombre clave del chavismo y ex ministro
de petróleo el pasado mes de marzo al
estrecharse el cerco judicial hacia su
entorno renunció al cargo desde entonces
se encuentra en paradero desconocido
para analizar la situación Contamos con
Mercedes de freitas directora ejecutiva
de transparencia Venezuela señora
freitas bienvenida France 24 le pido
Antes que nada empezar con un poco de
contexto De qué tratan exactamente
estas investigaciones masivas
puede muchísima información que ha
estado saliendo por parte del Estado por
desde hace más de 24 años en donde nos
informan del movimiento irregular de un
dinero que se supone tenía que haber
entrado al país por la venta de petróleo
ustedes saben que con las sanciones
económicas que se impuso que impuso el
mundo a Venezuela sobre todo al a la
empresa petrolera pues se hacía muy
difícil la venta del petróleo por parte
del gobierno eh Para triangular la venta
pues al principio se utilizaba Rusia y
las empresas Rusia rusas y los bancos
rusos pero con la invasión a Ucrania se
dificultó todo esto el gobierno empezó a
utilizar a cualquier persona digo
cualquiera como una exageración Por
supuesto que estuviera que tuviera
capacidad o prometiera que puede vender
el petróleo de Venezuela y de así se de
esa manera salieron muchos
barcos tanques para la venta sin embargo
ese petróleo al parecer no se estaba
cobrando lo que ofrece insólito es que
la información que ha salido es que esta
situación es desde el 2020 es decir
vamos para los años y medio y los montos
que el país ha dejado de de recibir
Bueno pues son inciertos hay gente que
dice que son tres mil millones y hay una
información de Rey de reuter que habla
hasta de veintiún mil millones de
dólares lo que lo que parece imposible
es que una empresa se le puedan perder
desaparecer o o seguir trabajando con un
hueco de tres mil millones de dólares
claro Pues precisamente de esta cifra de
3000 millones de dólares o hasta los
21.000 que usted señala le quería hablar
porque parece que algunos de esos
dineros han sido utilizados para crear
vías alternativas para comercializar ese
petróleo debido a las sanciones contra
Venezuela Le quiero preguntar cómo han
sido usadas esas sanciones para crear
nuevos esquemas de corrupción en el país
pues lo que nosotros supon
emos que ya abierto fuera de Venezuela
en los sistemas de justicia de otros
países Es que la opacidad que es Norma
en Venezuela desde hace más de 20 años
más la discrecionalidad y la falta de
rendición de cuentas en Venezuela no se
publican informes de rendición de
cuentas informes de gasto desde hace más
de 10 años y esta y esto lo que ha
creado es una un gran incentivo y una
gran oportunidad y riesgos de corrupción
no tenemos un sistema de justicia en un
sistema de contraloría que exija cuentas
y los venezolanos pues no tenemos
información de nada lo que va saliendo
por un lado por otro lo que tienen a
bien decir por Twitter a veces algún
ministro lo que ha estado pasando Es que
se ha cobrado se ha vendido el petróleo
con grandes descuentos Pero por supuesto
muchas de esas de esas oportunidades a
requerir a requerido que estos
operadores de la venta
sean también utilicen el dinero para
sobornos o para extorsionar o para
hacerse de grandes sumas de dinero por
el el tránsito poco formal y oscuro que
tiene que ser la venta de petróleo en el
país esto ha generado entonces que unos
pocos muy cercanos al Estado venezolano
muy cercanos al gobierno tengan la
posibilidad de vender el petróleo
venezolano lo que nos dice ahora por
primera vez desde hace muchísimos años
que se empieza a investigar esta gran
corrupción el fiscal actual de la de la
República venezolana lo que nos dice es
que la gran responsabilidad de todo lo
tiene un grupo que al parecer está todo
relacionado como bien decía la
introducción de esta nota con el
expresidente y exministro cree que la
isabín
no sabemos exactamente si la
investigaciones se van a quedar
solamente en ese ámbito de las personas
relacionadas con tarea que lanzami o
Por fin en Venezuela se van a abrir las
investigaciones a toda la gran red de
corrupción que domine y controle el
estado y que para que tengan un dato ya
hay ciento cuarenta y seis
investigaciones abiertas en los sistemas
de justicia de 26 países sin embargo en
Venezuela solo se está investigando esta
trama y hablando de El aissami ahora
mismo Está en paradero desconocido Usted
cree que podría llegar a ser juzgado
Bueno la verdad es que somos muy
incrédulos en Venezuela Porque después
de tantos años necesitamos como muchas
más pruebas para poder generar confianza
en que lo que nos están diciendo va a
ocurrir además que hay signos que no nos
gustan Por ejemplo la empresa petrolera
sigue sin presentar información real eh
el gobierno venezolano no ha presentado
cuentas sobre sus ingresos ni sobre sus
egresos Como le digo desde hace
muchísimos años y lo y una práctica
usada en el país con mucha regularidad y
que es fatal en la lucha contra la
corrupción es nombrar al al al
presidente de pedevesa como ministro de
energía petróleo el nombre del
ministerio cambia con regularidad porque
lo que lo que pasa allí es que se
elimina el sistema de contrapeso el
sistema de checan Balam el sistema de
contraloría que debe hacerse desde el
supervisor el supervisado al ejecutor
esta práctica vuelve a implementar ahora
con el nombramiento a la salida de toda
esta trama de la luz pública el
nombramiento del presidente actual de
pediavesa Por cierto tiene muy poco
tiempo tiene unos meses como ministro en
sustitución de tarea que la examen esta
práctica no nos da no no nos da buena
espina no nos hace pensar que de verdad
hay un intento de lucha contra la
corrupción Porque además hay muchas
otras tramas relacionadas con esto que
no se han investigado o que no nos han
dicho que se están investigando
señora defraitas le quiero hacer una
pregunta ya muy brevemente Y es que
algunas voces críticas califican esta
operación como una lucha política
oportunista cree usted que es así
podría ser no están es posible es más
posible eso que que realmente se esté
abriendo a un cambio estructural en el
país para darle lucha contra la
corrupción